foreign
death makes me think about what I want
to leave behind when I go how can we
honor and enjoy our lives while making
sure we won't burden our loved ones with
our stuff later now Zach it is true that
your coffin does not come equipped with
a hitch for a U-Haul
oh my patent pending
and and and yet we live our lives like
um like it does there's a book that came
out maybe three or four years ago called
The Gentle art of Swedish death cleaning
I'm sure some of you have heard of
Swedish death cleaning but it is
essentially preparing your stuff for
your death in a way or actually a better
way is preparing to not burden the
people in your life with this excess
stuff this whole thing with minimalism
started from me and Ryan I had to go
down to Florida to deal with my mom's
stuff I'd been down there a bunch of
times while she was going through chemo
and radiation which by the way talk
about prolonging suffering I mean it was
one of the worst things that she could
have done she had stage four cancer
eventually reached her brain and they
were just trying to prolong a life in
which she would suffer more at some
point and and with this tiny sliver of
hope that maybe I'll you know survive
this or whatever it was right but then
the last time I went down there it was
to deal with her stuff and the average
American household has 300 000 items in
it and I found this out firsthand and my
mom's tiny one bedroom apartment and she
it's not like she was a conventional
hoarder she just had a lot of stuff she
had 65 years worth of accumulations and
so the big antique furniture in the big
bed here and the cups and plates and
bowls and her towel closet and the
makeup chest and all of these different
things that we accumulate over time and
we don't think about okay I'm not using
these things but we hold on to it just
in case three most dangerous words in
the English language and then what
happens eventually when we die someone
else now has to deal with those things
and it's really difficult it's the
hardest thing to do is like this person
just left and now everything has some
sort of it's infused with this
sentimental value or at least we think
it is the story tell ourselves oh I
better hold on to this this is precious
this is precious this is precious but of
course if everything's precious nothing
is precious and I started letting go of
my mom's stuff realizing that I could
let go of it because
the memories aren't in the things
the memories are inside us and so I
could let go of the things and still
maintain the memories of my mother
now Zach I've heard you say this and
you've alluded to it here I'm just
really fascinated by this that the
memories that we have
are in the water in ourselves and I've
never heard anyone really talk about
that maybe you could clarify that a bit
for us
point out that if you're a pharaoh you
do get to have the U-Haul hitch you get
to bring it all you can bring it all
down in that sarcophagus
I think that's actually the simplest
approach obviously for dealing with the
stuff left behind the business yeah yeah
U-Haul bearing yeah yeah forget about
the coffin we're just gonna go with the
60-foot U-haul um
yeah no it's
um the stuff that we accumulate is you
know symptomatic of a life lived in in a
in the finite reality you know and so we
have this opportunity I think to when
you're writing your living well start to
look at the way you're living and see if
you're you are alive you know just do a
quick check-in like am I actually here
because if you're writing on if you've
got 72 pages and you're living will of
stuff and where it needs to go you can
just kind of ponder perhaps like wow
dude hey do I want my my loved ones to
deal with that when I'm done and B do I
want to deal with that for the next 50
years you know and so I think there's
this huge opportunity to live ready to
die and I love that so much that it's
like my my massive transformative
purpose I am the storm I'm ready to die
again today
hmm I love the energetics of being vital
I love the energy of being alive I love
the way in which being alive is so
ethereal like like a storm is
and yet I love that it's only in letting
go of everything that you've experienced
today that you get to keep living
because the moment you make today the
thing tomorrow is going to be heavier
and so this willingness to die to
yourself into everything you experience
today on the pillow every night is a
very powerful tool towards joy and I
have to I'm I've been on a 12-year
journey of just
extreme deconstruction of stuff around
me you know my relationship expectations
on self as a father as a husband is this
or that you know letting all of these
these roles go to be more and more of
the expression of me
and in that it's just been this you know
journey of starting to feel joyful at a
level that I didn't know was possible
for the first you know 45 years and so
in these last five years just starting
to feel alive and starting to think you
know in these next 50 years if I'm
willing to die every night on that
pillow and wake up fresher and more
clear from the burden of the water
crystals that we'll go into in a minute
I'm going to be vibrationally ecstatic
and that's ultimately the description
that I would say is what does it mean to
be alive it means that you are capable
of being vibrationally ecstatic
and that ecstasy can take on incredible
Stillness it's not like ecstatic like
bouncing around like I'm so happy I'm
the happiest person in the room am I
gonna go Shake everybody until they're
happy
it's more of this sense of vibrational
presence and for me I like what Harkens
to mind is the the sound of a blue whale
in the ocean
these long deep vibrations that actually
can travel the circumference of the
earth five times a single call of a blue
whale five times around the
circumference of the oceans and so
that's what it feels like to be
vibrationally ecstatic is it can be
heard five times around the world
because you are so clean in your
vibration so pure in that Essence but to
do it you're gonna have to let go and
let go and let go and let go and so are
you ready to die again so let's go into
the water structure that you asked about
a storm is so cool to me and I love it
as a sense of identity because
ultimately a storm is nothing right and
it's it's not the rain it's not the wind
that wind is wind the rain is rain it's
not the hail it's not the lightning
because lightning is lightning so what
the hell is the storm
um
storm is this
Center Point that like a conductor in an
orchestra spins these energies to play a
symphonic expression of beauty
and that beauty is destructive to
anything that was before so that it can
create such a fresh canvas for this
morning's Dawn and the smell of wet
Earth and the feeling of fresh breeze on
your skin when it's been cleansed
through the rain the storm is nothing
but it creates everything and that's
what I think it means to be living are
you capable of being nothing so that you
can take the beauty of the essence of
everything around you and spin it into
such a vibrational experience that it
would erase the past and you would be
only present in the beauty today
that's an exciting way to live life
are you willing to be nothing so that
you can be witness to everything did you
enjoy this Standalone patreon highlight
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com the minimalists or click the
link in the description your support
keeps our podcast and YouTube Channel
100 advertisement free
[Music]